we're counting down to the holidays with
the help of lifestyle and beauty advisor
don mccarthy who has some great gifts
for anyone on your list
hi las vegas happy holidays
first up is from a brand i actually just
started using this year and a great
stocking stuffer
mio skin care their solar powered
illuminating sugar body scrub pairs
golden sugar crystals with an
antioxidant rich blend of olive and
andaroba oils this citrus scented scrub
gently buffs away dead skin cells as it
delivers long lasting moisture the
result better skin from head to toe the
company believes in formulating natural
honest and clean body care that does not
harm you or the environment to purchase
this scrub go online to anthropology.com
next i have a great book mother's love
by diana alexandrova this story is
written from the point of view of 10
different animal moms ranging from
elephants to eagles and shows the reader
the various sides of motherhood
including joy resilience and sacrifice
mother's love is a lyrical celebration
of the unconditional bond
every mother has with her child and is
the perfect gift for mothers and
grandmothers so to order your coffee go
to donnybooks.com
now something new to just hit the market
that just premiered in september and is
absolutely free to watch that your kids
are going to love is the bubble brigade
flubbel and his bubble friends use songs
and games to teach letters numbers and
more and have just released their line
of children's products just in time for
this holiday season
from backpacks and activity books that
encourage learning to giant wands that
make the best bubbles i mean who doesn't
love bubbles to bathtub crayons that
activate with bubble magic you can join
in on the fun with flubble frankie
phoebe and jamie while watching the
bubble brigade just go to
thebubblesbrigade.com and that's bubbles
with an s to tune in and purchase any of
these fun products now if you are
wanting beautiful hair heading into the
holidays and the new year look no
further than a rising hair care products
two of my personal favorites from the
line are the 24 karat gold shampoo with
hyaluronic acid and the 24 karat gold
mask with hyaluronic acid all of their
products are crafted in italy and
designed to help both men yes men and
women maintain healthy looking hair and
nourish the scalp and hair follicles
arising was actually one of the first
hair care brands to launch in the
european market back in 1998
and the first to use apple stem cells in
their formulations which works to
promote healthy hair growth to purchase
go to arisingdashusa.com
lastly i love baking at the holidays and
one of my helpers is imperfect foods
they deliver grocery staples to
consumers nationwide helping to
eliminate food waste and build a better
food system for everyone they source
responsibly with sustainable meat and
seafood plant-based protein dairy pantry
staples and fresh produce that farmers
couldn't sell since they were quote ugly
with scheduled weekly deliveries
consumers save time money and the planet
and a great way to support unnecessary
waste as 35 of the food grown right here
in the us goes uneaten check out
imperfectfoods.com
now for more information on any of these
products just go to dawnscorner.com
until next year las vegas now merry
christmas and happy new year